uh
the
slide
with um
a few problems uh
a few fascinating bit
central ability problems in evolution
and uh
uh i'm
these are problems that i have thought
about okay a little and uh i'm going to
tell you so this is this is the part of
the talk where i stick my head out okay
you know and and
and uh
when you take appropriate action so uh
um
and but i want to
actually you know just just to show that
that i've been i've been i've been
watching uh modis live in stock you know
but i just want to remember something
from him uh
but um uh
so
my my full name is christopher dmitry i
don't know if anybody knows what a h
stands for it stands for
humidity okay right so
so um
actually hard is too so
so
the role of sex is is a is a well-known
interesting problem so there is there is
uh
15 years ago
nick barton in charge of wrote
him a famous survey uh a famous paper
qualified basically
setting it up
and uh
and what i want to say i mean i want to
connect this with what i you know the
way i ended my first half of my talk
with the two
genders of of
heuristics
evolution-inspired heuristics
simulate annealing and genetic
algorithms
so
what i'm saying is that the bigotry of
sex
the success the empirical fact of sexist
success in life
makes the apparent advantage of similar
engineering over genetic algorithms hard
to explain harder to explain
and
here is when sort of you know i
what really got me into studying
evolution is is meeting
a deal if not
but that's about seven years ago now uh
and during our first discussion uh
which lasted an inordinate amount of
hours um
why
i explained to him my frustration with
not understanding uh
this this this fact okay that that
simulator really works and generic
algorithms don't
and
in the end of this discussion
by the end of this discussion so you
know we looked at each other
and uh
we had uh this uh which basically is is
what what uh what madisla i believe uh
mentioned before what if
sex is a mediocre optimizer of fitness
okay
and
and let me
sort of you know
i will stick to two loss i uh
just because they provided me with a
two-dimensional screen to project them
okay you know but but uh but
everything i'll say sort of you know you
know also also extends to multiple let's
say
uh
so this is the fitness landscape of it
of an imaginary to gene organism
uh
and the
entries are the fitness of the
combination of the genotype
uh
and
i'll tell you things that we know
uh
now that uh asex
will select the largest numbers okay
so you're saying if you start with a
population that just kind of all over
covers the world yes right you know
these standard population covers all
over yes i mean also so
uh
all everything else will vanish soon and
and and
only only these genotypes will happen
will
and eventually sort of you know seven
will also uh wither away
okay now that's that's trivial okay so
you know it's
it's
physics okay
um
uh
now
now um
it's proven it's physics and you can
prove it okay
so now
so the interesting observation we made
and we called it mixability
is that sex
does not favor this
but favors something else favors the
alleles that perform well with many
genetic partners
okay if you wish
it's going to favor the the rows and
columns with large large averages
as opposed to the largest entries in
this matrix this is completely clear
okay so uh
i'm sure that um uh
many of you knew that um
many didn't so you know one one of one
of the reviewers of our of our
paper said
i will kick myself
you know for not uh
having thought of this one or the
graduate student you know so um
uh which is in some sense you know a
very underhanded you know a
high high underhanded high compliment
okay
and and uh
so this is uh this is uh this is uh uh
something here so let me let me give you
another sort of the more igurus
imagine that your landscape is like that
okay that you have uh peaks you have
valleys and you have a plateau okay
so you can actually prove
not hard
and that's that's again with with with
that d and mark feldman
that unless the peaks are more than
twice the plateau
the plateau will prevail under sex
okay so
sexual evolution will miss the speech
because they are only by ninety percent
higher than than the plateau so this is
a little bit of high recombination right
it's it's a high recombination yes right
now so
everything else else are you know you
know the quantitative parts of what i'm
going to say is about high recombination
but but similar things you can say about
lower recombination
so sort of you know these two will
change
for lower combination
okay so um this is
one thing i want to set forth all right
let me know that that there is you know
so you know that that we found
a
a particular manifestation of
what monday slatkin said before namely
that uh that uh
uh
evolution does not necessarily optimize
okay so you know
it
does it does its own thing okay so what
i want to show to continue showing
is uh
that there is a computational way to get
some a little more
uh
better understanding of what evolution
actually does okay so you know so let me
let me
uh
go to uh week selection
which is uh
sort of uh a uh
uh what is weak selection it's just it's
it's again
a point of view and evolution it has to
do with the motus
yes
so are you are you done talking about
the role of sex or are you no no no no
no no no will i ever
against parasites true yes
um
you know if you have an adversary who's
not
doing the optimal strategy it's actually
much harder to play okay so so uh so
excellent very good so that's you said
this is the traditional way of
explanation this is one of the five or
six or seven traditional ways of
explanation uh
i get i i mentioned
the paper by uh
barton and charlesworth they go they
sift through all these arguments
and they find them in conclusion okay so
you know they find that none of them
sort of you know is clearly so you know
they they they look at them
sympathetically so you know they believe
that one of these must work okay so you
know but but but it's
but this paper i beat to me says that
it's still it's still a little open so
you know what
okay
um
all right so
let me let me you remember these
landscapes that i showed you before
so these are like extreme rough
landscapes okay you know
life is really hard here right now so
as as as
lars said yesterday i know there is a
very famous you know 1969 uh
stance in evolution by by kimura saying
that uh evolution is neutral okay so you
know then this has been held has
suffered friendly amendments okay so you
know since then basically saying that
it's not neutral but it's sort of nearly
neutral and there is a mathematical
incarnation of this near neutrality
which is called the weak selection
and basically the quick selection says
that uh uh the fitness landscape does
not look like the sort of extreme uh one
that i've been showing you before but it
looks sort of like this okay where uh of
the fitness of the particular genotype
and again i'm i'm talking about two
right now i'm showing you two to loci
but uh what i'm going to tell you is is
true for
for uh multiple sites
uh the
um
the
fitness of particular genotype is
essentially
about the same all right well plus a
small number which is much much less
closer than smaller than one actually
it's much much smaller than r their
combination ratio okay so but but uh
certainly one
and
r mean okay the minimum recombination
ratio between any two the lost side that
you are going to
to examine okay or two sets of loss i
okay but for two for two for two losses
one number but is it much also much
smaller than one over the size
population it is it is about the size no
it's it's not much smaller but you know
you think of it as as as smaller as the
size of affiliation yes you know it's
it's about the same the same as right
right yeah
uh
but i mean for for what i'm you know
it's very much smaller than one is sort
of you know is a good it's a good place
to start
okay um
so there is
a really important theorem of nagilaki
who
says the following that under week's
selection
lingers this equilibrium vanishes okay
lingard's equilibrium for for those for
the computer science mathematicians
audience is uh
is basically the distance of a
distribution over a rank one
distribution of the product distribution
okay
and and the maximum you know the minimum
distance and uh
and the other weak selection you don't
have substance okay that basically the
these probabilities are
essentially a product distribution if
you forget a small error
okay
uh
and that holds after uh
not logan too logan with generations all
right i mean also if r where n is the
number of alleles total number of values
your also recombination is strong
right right yeah so so i recommend so
everything sort of you know has uh
things like one over our
you know yeah
then like the inverse population size
then selection right right yes yes yes
yes right yeah yeah
that's the minimum recombination the
meaning of a combination between any two
sets you know what we're talking about
so you know and and so on yes
yeah so
the one over in there
yes you know first of all uh this is
infinite population right you know this
lengthy population uh
uh approximation anyway right i mean but
you are right okay so you know you're
right
one of the less is over here
um
okay
the equations
of you know the the very currents
it becomes like this
okay in other words you don't want to to
track the genotype now the genotype
frequencies you just want to track the
layer frequencies
is it clear
and the other frequencies change like
this that the next the next day
the next generation
uh valid frequency sorry is multiplied
by this uh this little thing here
which uh
first of all okay it makes the point of
the mixability thing that i told you
right i know that
that uh
that that i told you before five minutes
ago
uh mixability says basically
that evolution favors alleles that can
do well
with
a
wide range of partner orders
and
if you wish
this is what this says right i mean it's
that they increase by a factor which
explicitly depends on how well they do
with other values
okay so what i'm saying is that is that
the fisheries equations even for two
genes are
uh
complicated so you know i enjoy staring
at them but that's all you know but but
what i'm saying is that is that the
legacy they become extremely simple okay
so you know and allow you to uh and this
takes a little manipulation all right
you know it's not completely better
and allow you to to make a few
interesting remarks one of them is what
i just told you
uh
here's another one okay and tell me how
you like it
so
here's what this equation tells me
and what this equation should tell you
right
that
under
week selection okay the only the only
assumption i've made
the
revolution international selection
becomes a game
okay i'm not i'm i haven't defined what
the game is but uh how many would like
me do
okay okay bye find out something before
you say yeah because
are there non-trivial solutions
fixed-point solutions of these equations
uh non-trivial yes actually
yes i mean
yeah so the y's where the y's are
neither zero one yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes there are you know there are i
mean no they're they're rare but they
exist
you are you are right there there are
deltas for which they exist
exist yes i mean
you know i have
i'm in the middle of a debate about
exactly this point yes yes yeah okay
uh yes they exist
um
okay
so what is a game
uh by a game i mean the following it's a
you know it's basically what for neumann
nash and so on call again which is uh
it is a thought experiment
whose purpose is to understand the
rational behavior
regard behavior by rational agents and
the game is defined as follow
you have
a finite set of players
each player has available a final set of
actions
and if all players each chooses one
action
this action combination
imputes a particular utility on each one
of the players
and this utility is not in advance
and basically what what game theory does
it tries to understand how do these
people behave so you know what do you
expect them to do okay so in the end you
have equilibria
mixed strategies nobel prizes and so on
okay right so okay
all right
so
here is something that i hope
will surprise you okay
uh
i didn't know it uh a few months ago so
let me know and really i hope you didn't
know it
but under the quick selection
evolution is a game
okay who are they who are the players
important
the players are the loser
okay
so
uh if this reminds you of the selfish
gene think again okay it's not that all
right no it's not about that
uh so the places are the los angeles the
players are losing so every player has a
set of actions strategies what are these
actions
the actions the strategies
uh
are the alleles of the losses okay so
every player has has uh has
controversial as you know in game theory
uh players typically
occasionally often usually
use mixed strategies okay in other words
they're randomized by their inputs okay
so so i have to ask to answer now
the strategic values what are the
probabilities with which every player
that is every locus plays a strategy
that is valid and
and
here's what it is so by the way i'm not
making this up okay i am reading the
equation i gave you before okay
so all this is is sort of you know an
imaginative reading
but precise reading of the equation i
gave you before okay putting it in a
different framework
the the common utility in other words
here is what this makes it distinct from
a selfish gene that these loci
they have a common utility okay they
strive for the same thing all right this
is called the coordination game in some
sense it is the simplest kind of game
all right i don't know
some people will call it no game at all
okay but it is a game okay game theory
study coordination game
and and this game is only interesting
when uh when uh the players are
cognitively challenged okay
because otherwise they could sort of you
know they and lord there is a lot right
i mean they are concretely cognitive
challenge okay no they cannot sort of
you know all right so
so
the common utility
is the organism's fitness okay that's
what all the laws are striving for
to optimize expected organisms fitness
all right
let me repeat i'm doing nothing else
but read this equation
all these
is from
again theoretic rating of this equation
nothing else
all right
right
surprise
what the players do how the players
behave okay every you know they they
update their strategies
what the players do they play by the
multiplicative weights update
miraculous algorithm that i showed you
before okay so
so
uh
okay
my friend umash okay with
whom i wrote this i mean they used to
ask me
i mean what is
what algorithm would have created all
this
all this
in uh
in a mere
10 to 12 steps okay
because that's you know we heard
yesterday that's that's how many that's
how many generations i'll come to you
yeah that's how many generations we had
we had we have had uh since uh since the
beginning
so
um
10 to 12 may sound like a big number but
it's not okay you're you know since the
beginning of my talk your cell phone has
done more than that
has taken more steps than the ten to the
twelve
ten to the thirty is a big number ten
thirty
is a great number okay if you think
about it
that 10 to 30 is is is how much all cell
phones in the world are doing in a year
they don't accomplish much believe me
i saw your bid and raised it so we know
with something better okay yeah so yeah
all right so um
okay
so um
uh
and uh i saw so i mean as i said i know
bench was asking me what kind of
algorithm could produce all this in 10
10 to 12 steps i mean
you know in some sense you know we we
have an answer okay you know we know
what kind of algorithm
um
not to rate too much into it so you know
there is there is a there is a lot of it
that it doesn't that it leaves out okay
you know but but so you know it's i find
it extremely interesting that this
algorithm that that
has created created a shock of surprise
to computer science over the past
years is uh you just you just find it
when you look under the hood of of of
evolution of natural natural selection
um
there's a little more question up there
sorry sorry sorry
yeah so i i obviously haven't read your
paper and i can't necessarily do this in
my head but but this this thing that you
just said this is this is the levels of
selection problem and um so the price
equation
formulation i mean no it's it's not it's
you know it's it's not that it's it's
definitely not prices equation
yeah no it's it's not price equation
it's not the fundamental theorem yeah
it's something else
um okay so so you checked out like
stephen i i know i know i know i know
you know we call you know i know about
price equations sort of my co-author is
no better than me you know so so yes i i
know it's something else
yeah i mean i will be delighted to hear
from you if you see a connection
um
okay
any questions
so as monday slacking said you know
don't tell me it's that it's the
fundamental theory okay
okay so there is there is a little more
which i think is sort of you know
remember
i wanted to tell you a few things a few
random thoughts that i've had about the
role of sex
and sort of you know frankly
this equation this algorithm
is enabled by sex without sex you don't
have this
you know sex is
at the basis of the of the of the long
chains or you know that that creates
this algorithm
recombination
um
okay
so here is something that that
uh
a couple of computer scientists knew it
was written obscurely in a few papers in
a couple of papers but so you know
we
if you want so we're gonna give you a a
a very rigorous derivation okay
this the same equation
in other words the
the multiplicative weights update
applied
to a little frequencies
can be represented very interpreted as
an online optimization problem okay so
here's what i mean
let's make the following photos better
all right
you say i bet
that each locus
at each generation
is trying to optimize something
okay so let's reverse engineer
what is it that every locus is trying to
maximize is this clear
are you together so you know so so the
and there is a very crisp mathematical
mathematical
uh answer to this
and it and it entails uh
variation in evolution
okay
so here is here is what it does
at each generation each locus is
striving to maximize as if
the sum of two things
the cumulative expected fitness of the
organism over all previous generations
okay so
it's sort of trying to optimize
something that looks like sort of you
know uh looking too much to the back
okay and and it's a little
it's a little puzzling to me to us
okay so the first thing means
that what happened hundred generations
ago is equally important to the locus as
as what happened the last generation
okay
so it's a sum okay no way it's nothing
okay it's a sum it's a straight sum
the cumulative expected thickness
of the organism over all previous
generations
plus
one over s
which is a huge which you see of course
it's a huge multiplier times the entropy
of the average distribution
okay so what i'm saying is that
implicit
in the equations of life under natural
and other weak selections
on in the equations of of of revolution
of natural selection
under week selection
is the fact
that
what
these things are trying to optimize to
maximize
one of them given actually a lot of
weight and the smaller the selection the
selection strength
the bigger the weight
is the entropy of the least distribution
okay which
to computer scientists is a synonym of
variation
okay
yes that's a reminiscent of the free
energy which is uh the sum of enthalpy
and entropy where enthalpy here would
correspond to the thickness
could be could be so you know i you know
what what uh what i'm um
uh it i'm sure that this has has a
physics analog what i'm saying you know
so
i'm
what i'm saying is this okay i'm saying
the following precise thing
but if you write this plus this
okay
and you take the kkt conditions
and you try to maximize it overall
overall uh pijs okay overall xi xi's
okay overall sort of you know
allele frequencies overall set of a
little frequencies so basically what you
are doing
is you are
maximizing
overall
overall possible vectors of our allele
distributions
at its generation okay your market you
are you're
you are you are you are optimizing over
this
the following is the sum
overall t overall up to now okay sorry
of
essentially the
expected thickness of the organism which
is some which is x i
times the fitness
of of
of at time t
of uh expected fitness valid or valid
time t
plus
one over s if u is minus one over s the
sum
overall overall i
of uh p x i
uh l n x i
so
this is i'm rewrote this okay
now what i'm saying is that this is a
simple concave
maximization problem it's a it's a
complex problem
strictly convex problem it has your
unique opinion
you can find it but it's a convex
because it's it's something linear times
minus something
something of x so it is exactly the
frame sorry
it's exactly the free energy
it's exactly the free energy you're
saying
uh okay the expectation of the energy
minus the energy
expectation of the energy minus
so
you the maximum you you have you have
omitted something okay that i'm adding
over all previous generations
um
so the problems we talked about um
uh earlier one can also think of the
time as being a direction if i think of
it energy of a polymer i mean that then
it becomes a similar thing but it's just
the time
so so there's not time in the in the
position okay so you know
yeah
i'm not i know
i'm not i'm not i'm not saying that this
is new okay so you know you know i'm
actually i'm saying that computer
scientists have discovered okay about
about a few years a few years back
what i'm saying is that is that is that
um
uh
so
i'll i want to see if it's exactly what
you're saying so you know that but you
know we do have physicists you know in
our in our in in our
cultures right you know so but uh
i'm sorry
sorry i'm sorry to hear them
the fitness term is summed over time but
not the um not the trajectories you're
not maximizing trajectories
i'm not i'm not exactly i mean so i'm
maximizing right now so so i'm talking
about right now
the fitness takes the whole time right
but you're not maximize the entropy of
the whole trajectory it's just the end
points okay so i'm not gonna actually
know that
okay so so uh i mean
if it's identical with something i'll be
equally delighted so you know i'm i'm
telling you it's something obvious yeah
so no it's it's it's identical to
something that that manfred garfurt has
has said in but i mean being said very
clearly in the paper about 10 years ago
uh
it's also identical to something that
lorenzo reikia
you know
has said another data recently okay so
so but i mean i don't have pride of
discovering this
i'm just i have uh i'm just
very interested in it okay i'm keenly
interested right i mean because it sort
of tells you
that uh
variation sort of noise is in some sense
an obsession of the beast okay so we
know it's by it's part of what it tries
to optimize
okay
any more any more questions okay so
that's this is this is sort of uh
you want to see these derivations or you
know it's it's just differentiating this
stuff and putting some of the ground
multiplier
yes
sorry okay sure yeah so basically what
what you want
uh you also have
you have this okay yeah and and exci
negative
uh
and but you know but even ignoring this
sort of you know ignoring ignoring the
lagrange multiplier for this
you basically get
that uh
what what what the what the kkt
conditions would give you
is that
f5 i believe
equals
1 plus
an x i
and basically
uh
this will give you
that um
sorry
uh
t is not like this is an index right
yeah thanks
um
and basically this will tell you so am i
doing something wrong here
in the differentiation
so solving this will tell you that x
is because that's what we're talking
about
x i t plus one
uh
is
sort of to get the normalization we have
to look at the previous t and and and
and
but it's essentially uh
x i
times one
x i t
plus
t
is no no tau is the tau is the running
index
uh to get this solution you have to
rewrite this for t equals t minus one
and and subtract
um
x of
e times
sorry
s times
f i tau which is this
sorry not one plus x which is
which is again
one plus s
times
which exactly
and i may have missed the sign somewhere
but and also i also jumped over
the derivation where i rewrite this for
t equals t minus one and subtract
so again
looking at this and comparing with this
what it tells what it tells you is that
is that
the visualize equations in this
particular case
they optimize they optimize this
they optimize this convex combination
which again
has
as a prominent term
interview
okay
so i mean
doing this brings back memory i mean
i've done this before i've done i've
done this sort of like years ago so this
is not this is no you know i'm sure that
this is a very common derivation but
what i'm saying is it's also applied
here
all right so
uh let's change the subject all right
ah
so i don't know how many of you know
about pointer dots
so you know they are okay
all right so pointer dogs are dogs
trained so that so that when there is
life in the environment
uh they point it okay
so a pointer dog in this room will be
totally confused
this particular point though ponderdog
is pointing at
young charles darwin
darwin was
was very interested in pointerdog so
interested that he had befriended the
shady characters in the
london suburbs that razer
and and uh
the way they raise pointer dogs is sort
of interesting
they take good the good hands and they
are they train them to point
they select the best desk pointers
they build them they they
they teach the puppies how to point
and after a while they have created
better dogs that point
okay
very interesting okay so um
this particular pointer dog is pointing
at uh
cereal waddington okay one of the
greatest experimentalists of the 19th
century right so
um and what i want to tell you is an
experiment after that
so um
uh he took
a uh so you can tell a computer
scientist
because he tells this he calls his
animals flies okay you know so some
computer science right so uh so he uh uh
so he took a bunch of flies
and and uh that that was in any borough
in in
i believe in the
1980s 1950s
and what he did is he raised the
temperature uh from room temperature to
20 degrees to by 40 degrees
actually he
cooked the puppet for for for for a
while uh
and and and and um
to 40 to 40 degrees and as a result
something changed okay so you know what
really changed was not the head did not
become red as a point as as they depict
but
the rather wings became less cross
hatched than than they should be okay so
so there was there was some kind of
phenotypical change some kind of notable
phenotypical change
so
about 15 of them changed
so what he did
is is he repeated this and then
he bred
the geneva only where only the chains
flies and suddenly 60 percent had
changed
okay and then he continued
he bred again and some like 63 percent
change so the the changed flies
kept increasing
until they became all of the taller the
flies have changed
and then he did something else
he lowered the temperature
and the next generation about 25 of them
have changed
which to me is very surprising
okay this is a phenomenon that
that was called i'm not sure that
waddington called it but it's called
genetic assimilation adaptations to
environment become genetic okay that can
become inheritable
and uh i mean all the more you think
about it if you are not if you are not
sort of you know i have a
true biology so you know the more you
see the sort of respect of lamarck
all right so you know that this is uh
this is
something really fishy going okay
and
of course there is also the siberian
foxes you know that that we have heard
recently and so right i mean so that's
uh uh
but
don't worry okay the yeah
um
so there's a question is there a genetic
explanation can you find a purely
generic explanation this is sort of you
know the mental exercise i want to take
us through and there is okay sorry no
and
so what you want to do
is you want to find a function let's say
a boolean function
of of two variables of several variables
a genetic variable and environmental
variable h means high temperature it's
also zero one okay so
so basically you want
x is many variables many boolean
variables many zero one variables
you want
the probability you know in the
beginning you have let's say that only
all x i's are zero one with probability
half
in the beginning uh the probability the
sort of you know the starting
probability is zero percent okay so you
know you will never see a change fly
because the temperature is low
then you uh
then you
hit uh the puppet and suddenly you see
the 50
uh
of uh uh you know by the same problem
the flies are changed
then
you break them you breed a changed
flight
and you see that that
that the next day
sixty percent have changed and in fact
it's significant that this is slightly
bigger than fifty percent okay if you if
you do that you do that if you do the
calculation after you know you'll see
that it's sort of magically like 57 60
um
after successive breedings becomes 100
but then if you lower the temperature
from one to zero
it stays to 25 okay so this is what you
want to
to achieve right i mean so this is the
specifications of my of the of the
function i want to create right of the
boolean function i want to create in
these let's say 11 boolean variables 10
genes and an environmental variable
okay
it's a very simple function anybody
wants to guess
it's a threshold function right so so
here is here is the
you know incidentally they should have
told you this uh in computer science you
love boolean functions all right i don't
know so and we and we a lot of my work
even though the first time i'm
mentioning here
a lot of our work is about boolean
functions okay so so
we saw we had to indulge when we saw
this right i mean also in any way
suppose that red head is this boolean
function of 10 genes and high
temperature you know that that red head
means that
the sum of the ten genes
plus three times this variable is ten
okay suppose that this is a function
right and this is what a redhead means
it turns out
suppose that the genes are independent
random variables a little hard to follow
but not in terms of uh after the week
selection uh slide i showed you before
uh
with p i initially have
so if you if you buy all this all
properties of the whole experiment are
satisfied okay so you know so basically
you you create exactly like what you
become scattered
okay
with with these with these parameters
this is clear
and so i was really very happy very very
proud when i figured this out and then
i did it not pointed out that in 1958 uh
a natural is called stern
actually in america in the general
american naturalist and essentially
proposed exactly the same
yeah i should be curious you know
what's the best fit okay
so that's uh
um
so this is um
now
this is uh
uh
this is i think a nice exercise you know
and the exercise that you could predict
that computer scientists who have taken
so you know if we have gone to go
through
but then um
here's what got into us okay no we said
how about arbitrary boolean
right
how do you call it um
this is something that uh had always
been interesting okay so you know
what you know can we can we say
something about
very sort of arbitrary functions of of
of genes right i mean
besides besides the
sort of
simple threshold functions right
and
so what if we have an arbitrary boolean
function of genes and in fact now we
dispose of the environmental variable
age okay there is no environment right
there is no environmental
right i know we only only let let let
the populate population evolve right i
mean also
without without sort of having a control
and environmental control over it
and suppose that the satisfying
genotypes have a fitness fitness
advantage in other words the genotypes
that satisfy
are let's say slightly above uh
are slightly more fit than the
non-satisfying genotypes okay in uh in
what did some experiments of course the
satisfying genotypes
had an absolute advantage okay because
they survived i don't know everybody
else was wiped out you know so
so
will this trade be fixed eventually
do you expect this thread to be fixed of
course
if this is a nonsense finder of
assignment okay this is not not such
unsatisfiable formula a satisfiable
boolean variable
function
this is not going to happen okay so you
must have at least a way of satisfying
it but in fact
uh you should have
some some reasonable probability that's
fine okay in other words if you have a
large population a few people should if
you a few members of this population
should satisfy at random this this uh
this formula
in an event suppose you have such a
boolean formula but otherwise arbitrary
will this trade be fixed eventually okay
and
so
of course it's this is computer
scientists starting from a nice biology
experiment and so you know taking the
tangent
but so you know
we it turns out so this this is another
story i want to tell you
but
with our group we proved a very
interesting theorem about boolean
functions so let me know that the answer
is yes you can you can do this for every
boolean part
all right uh
and uh
so this is uh
work with adidas nat aviyad rubenstein a
student greg valiant former student now
at stanford and andrey wong who is with
a fellow this semester
and the theorem says
that any boolean function of genes which
confers a non-perception selection
advantage will be fixed
and when i say will be fixed i mean with
high probability within polynomial being
generations and with polynomial
population
polynomial the number of genes
the probability of satisfaction yeah the
probability of satisfaction let's say
yes so so it's so it's it's it's
polynomial the number of genes and
okay right so there's just one genotype
then you're cooked yes right right right
yeah or if there is no genotype then
even more okay and even
i can't even i'm not allowed to even
cluster all of the satisfying no no no
so sorry you know they're uniformly
distributed no no no no they're not any
for any function
the satisfying ones i can you could
because it
like n square or n cubed
in our case is n to the fourth
so it's basically it's uh
so it's it's it's it's it turns out it's
a finite population result but the
population does not have to be
incredibly large okay for this to work
okay it would be working the limit for
the large populations but but it only
needs to be
n to the fourth
where n is the number of genes
and maybe also multiplied by one over
epsilon to the fourth where epsilon is
like one-tenth the probability that that
that that is that a random genotype has
has a tree
but you're saying you can fix epsilon
and then take enlarge right right right
right so it's polynomial so it's you
know
frankly i
if memory serves it's one over it's n
over epsilon or if you wish we call it
uh
pi zero the probability that in the
beginning
uh you satisfy raised to the fourth
power
and um
maybe i may be i may be
slightly wrong about the four okay i
don't remember if if it multiplies both
or not that's how long the timer that's
that's and how large the population has
to be
for this to take hold
can i just ask an intuitive question
let's suppose whatever n you choose i
choose pi zero to be
one over n right fine and then it sends
me end to v
well anyway no but we know in that case
that it won't
it won't necessarily
uh go to three stations why is it
because you are going to miss it in the
beginning yeah you're going you're going
to be stuck i'm just trying to fit that
oh sorry
and
and scenario yeah
yeah i understand
so here you here here i i think i
misspoke you know i didn't explain
something n is the number of genes yeah
so i i we're mixing up the end here in
the final population yes right yeah yeah
so n is the number of genes how do you
what variable you want to use
the random genotype or the fraction of
genotypes that satisfy
the fractional genotypes of boolean
so so if it's small then of course you
have to have a large population sample
okay
okay and
i'm not sure that this is accurate and
i'm sure it's not optimal okay that we
can be brought down so you know we and
uh okay it just seems strange because
like i could say
i take
i i i
don't
have high
uh
i want to say like i had a bunch of i
want my relevant i wouldn't hear them to
sound strange by the way that's great
yeah i don't want to say yeah yeah yeah
i can say
of course
i love that okay so tell me no no i was
taking pi not to zero in my head yeah
well it sounds strange to me because it
seems to be inconsistent with alden's
results that advantageous alleles have
fixed the flow probability
are fixed with
so so i'm not so this is not does not
say that that alleles will be fixed
there are many ways to to to to fix this
you know this this is a this is a this
is a mutagenic trait
that has many ways of you know many many
ways of getting there
so it's the phenotype the phenotype will
be fixed
this is infinite it's a very combination
sorry it's it's it's
right yes the thing which is which
comes in here is what are you know
in in toy situations what are reasonable
um assumptions about how pi naught
depends upon the number of genes
yeah so that's one of these ones about
you know how many solutions there are
so for for threshold functions it's
already usually it's huge right i mean
it's like it's like a big big part of
the big part of the cube yes right
but but for other functions maybe
smaller you know but we want it to be
like reasonably large for this to work
do you know what the final population
looks like so is there a lot of
diversity in the final population
no there's not you know so so
in our proof technique you lose also
genetic diversity but i suspect that
there is a different proof technique
that gives you a much much better result
and also maintains genetic papers in
other words you know others you know
yeah good good point
okay
so uh
i can't believe you guys let me finish
my talk okay you know so uh
so quickly uh
you know you you know this you know
like we like wanting to experiment i
mean this this does not involve mutation
but basically it involves
as you know a strange manipulation of
of allylic frequencies so that so that
the phenotypic uh
property emerges
all right
so
i i started
explaining what computer science brings
to the table
uh
and uh you know i think it's a lot i
think i think i'm really proud of what
you bring to the table it doesn't
compare what you guys bring to the table
okay you bring to the table
the world's most fascinating most
important problem
and and
and a lot of brilliant work done on it
for the past 100 years
and uh but sort of you know you can you
know i i hope i convince some of you
that uh
computational insights can be reasonably
productive so you know you can they can
at least make you think in a in a
slightly new way about about things that
we knew
uh
so i'll tell you two random problems
that jumped to my mind so you know this
morning because i thought i should i
should put some some of the problems is
there an analytical proof of the
mixability principle of the fact that
uh that that that alleles that are
mixable or prevail
are favored
uh
and is the fact that i told you you
sorry the implicit maximization
more general phenomenal evolution which
uh
i guess
as as as a as i gathered from our
discussion a few minutes ago many of you
believe that
all right so um
any questions more general computational
speculations
the question coming back to the
liverpool paradox
which i thought of evolution but what
you're talking about here
it does but if i
look at the natural gases that were
interesting phenotypes the pi note is
exponentially small
in various things
um
the
and so that this would be the things
you think about i don't know i have no
idea
if one sort of thing
that somehow evolutionists fall pretty
hard
pretty hard problems um that you have to
beat out things already there but you
could do that by making a new function
of winning what happens
it seems like one of those sort of
questions in in
you know sort of toy models that
go
you know beyond the simplest one because
i think the blue function and the ones
where everyone may not be able to prove
the information will start getting some
insights and
go forward on that because this is
really you know getting to the issue of
the very large number of possible
solutions right right of course of
course yeah
which at least my sense is that i find
it hard to find things about literature
and literature
with a large number of solutions yeah
emphasizing emphasizing i seriously
seriously you know representatively
relevant for why genomes are the size
they are why they don't need to be any
bigger
very smaller scale why you know 20 amino
acids enough right proteins besides
there are a lot of sort of things in
there which um
or maybe we can use some of that
information okay also the fact that
recombination rates are very low
um also somehow
you know what is that
what sets the combination mendel didn't
stumble on them
well the low recombination rates i mean
you're kind of talking about that here
right you're saying right you don't want
to huh i don't know
yeah
yeah but you said like you know it's
it's not so good if you these higher
combinations are not so good actually
for finding the the uh good solutions
for getting for increasing fitness
uh
i guess right yes but i'm you know but
but right okay so um so you i i talked a
lot about genetic algorithms right amino
and and and uh
that's not what i'm interested in okay
you know so and actually genetic
algorithms are using using using the
genetic metaphor in order to solve
optimization problems if you look at
literature
you'll see that the researchers are more
mesmerized by evolution
than interested in in solving actual
problems okay you know so this this is
what you know this is what and
i am like that okay you know so uh
uh
right uh
i
yes i mean if if i really wanted if i
really need to solve the problem i would
use i would not use the combination but
maybe
you wouldn't use very high recombination
necessarily
and so maybe this is connected to why
recombination rates are not infinite in
actual population right right right
right okay okay okay okay it could be
could be here but the combination rate
is the easy thing for organizing
organisms to change around by you know
least fashionable and you know you know
long-time skills
so it's in you know microbes by enormous
factors and it's one where the sort of
balance of that of the
advantages of recombination and the
obamacare's
yeah
so
part of what christos is saying though
the way he's too humble to say it
himself is that he's
advocating a bit of a shift from the
notion of evolution as being
uh optimization survival and fitness to
being
maybe something different so survival of
mixable trait survival of modular traits
that if you accept sex as a fact of
evolution
then
what you get is not something which says
that
the organisms around us are kind of
fittest but rather the organisms around
us are the ones whose genomes are the
most mixable but this this is something
where it really depends on whether on
how how much sex we're talking about
right like whether sex overwhelms
selection or whether selection will
shift the composition of what genomes
are out there
and then what what is mixable changes
right sure sure but
but
the picture changes once you take into
account that maybe fitness is not the
goal of evolution
i don't know what to go but the i'll say
like that the strong recombination
picture is uh i think the problem is
fitness is not an office not one thing
it's an extremely high dimensional
object
and certainly the other way which is
they relate
i think at all is that the big advantage
of sex is with undefended environments
and therefore the fitness is time
dependent and many different problems
that that may solve but it's the keeping
the diversity of the population because
they're all sex which you
just talked about but then also
back aside again
i want to talk about a couple of things
so you know but yes i know yeah right
or even without time dependence i mean
just
uh on the way to the goal when you
actually need to produce the best
solution it helps to have more variation
right right right yeah yeah yes i mean
also
in the very end so you know
at equilibrium
very likely i mean actually most likely
this will be there will be no variation
at all
yeah
from an outsider's perspective
um
maybe maybe
what is
what
from where i can see you've got a bunch
of different people to think about
different things
accumulated for a semester and
what are kind of major
if you
in your sort of ideal world what would
come out of what are the kinds of
questions that would have some sort of
answers to this by the end of the
semester
so i mean all the the
the ones the ones that were discussed
and then they had put in the beginning
of
you know are amazing uh
you know are amazing questions you know
that's uh
the role of sex how is variance
maintained
how novelty emerges
maybe what is modularity and how it
emerges
so these are you know these are
these are
great deep questions i mean i'm sure
there are
four of 20 you know and uh what what i
want to be achieved sort of you know
solving you know answering uh definitely
very a few of them would be amazing okay
you know but
creating an environment where people
forge lifelong ties
research styles you know people from
people from the who wouldn't do so
otherwise
would be also an excellent uh outcome
we could try to ask a similar question
tomorrow
one can add so for example
discuss the first talk uh the problem of
of variation right
how to explain the amount of variation
that exists in nature that's a very big
uh problem even even today and evolution
has not yet been resolved
um and then it's the same problem came
up again
uh at the end of erasmus talk right or
when when
that neutrally selectionist debate
came up yet again even though it's been
going on for a very long time and there
is yet no resolution for it this
question came up of
of how much for example of the
drosophila genome and how much of the
human genome is is is experiencing
natural selection
and whether that and and what what
explained the the extent
of genetic variation that exists
and and as an example christos just
presented here
um
one new way of thinking about the
maintenance of genetic
variation that has not been
proposed before
so it really exemplifies the kind of
contributions that one can make to to
the study of evolution
but does that does that make sense
covers covers me yes yes
i think in some sense i mean
your goal in one way is too immodest and
no one's not going to solve these these
questions but there's a seems to me this
but it's too modest another way it's
certainly what i would like to come out
of this is a much better framing of
questions so these questions which all
these people frame some mathematical
very limited way some of these big uh
big picture picture ways and turning
some of those or preferably even more
new ones injured questions which one can
think of a well-defined answer
and then of course to figure out which
of those might be interesting from the
from the biology but it seems that the
really advanced field one needs a lot
more which you've talked about somewhat
doing of trying to really frame the
questions well and i think that's um uh
you know it's there's a much too much
tendency um and this that i didn't like
about your talk of going and starting
with all the dead white males and
quoting from them
and those they're the very big picture
questions but that was needed the very
big picture and the very small picture
in the sense of the population tedx the
mathematical questions of the underlying
framework of that the it really is the
sort of all the things in between and
really framing those questions um in a
way to try to
performance
that's
serious
on this point so uh in terms of this
role of diversity
so certainly one can one can see that
diversity plays a role
when there's uncertainty about the
future
you know to try to
you know to
to try to make sure one is one one is
hedging against possible futures i think
one of the one of the things that came
across in this you know one of the
features of what christmas was talking
about is that it comes up also for a
computational reason which is that
you're exploring and an environment
computationally and it's difficult and
and so this notion of diversity or
regularization you know that that you
want to you don't want to fit
you don't want to fit the part of the
data that you you know that you you
don't want to take the part of the
search space that you've already
explored and take it too seriously and
therefore you you want to maintain as
much diversity as possible
uh to do this just as a computational
mechanism for optimization you know this
is the
this is an
which
is that that balance so do you go for do
you specialize for your current
circumstance or do you remain a
generalist right genomically
and
you know sure it seems like that depends
on competition rate and recombination
rate yeah i i talked about echoes of
this yesterday
very good
so i'm wondering if you accept the
results of your statements of your
theorems
as a ground truth how much of the
uh what was known how much we have
checked the proofs we have checked the
proof
everybody does
so uh my question is
how how much of the origin what was
known in biology
you can actually get i mean if you
accept as truth
the statement
of the theorem how much of
of what
these other fields have investigated
if you have thought about this um
okay one of the what was known as
in in evolution or in genomics you can
actually
i've been in this business for a long
time okay you know so sorry so
um
there are there are so many ways to
answer what you are asking okay so you
know
so the question is um
uh
you know there is something there is
something uh
hubristic arrogant sort of you know
about proving theorems about anything
right i mean because because the
question is or you know that theorems
are something that you cannot you cannot
you cannot uh
you cannot uh uh
dispute and yet so we know
they they have they have they have they
have a sort of an unreasonable power
and so you you know in formulating your
theorems you should be extra careful and
of course okay that's that's that's uh
that's uh
what can i say here is one little thing
that i want to say right i mean
in in
what uh
what a theoretician does okay
these proof theorems about what other
people know empirically uh
and so we know in in
the best of all worlds uh
proves the theorem that utterly
surprises them and moves them all in a
different direction who moves the school
of fish in a completely different
direction
uh
what happens usually proves something
that that people say yeah
i knew i knew all that thanks for making
me sure okay so um
and
the vast majority of theories have
proved so you know in my career
is that what you were asking
sorry i'm asking basically there are
some uh
let's say some
let me use the term axiomatic uh
principles uh if you accept this as
ground truth what you have you have the
statement of the theory can you actually
recover what was originally known people
were suspecting oh we have this model
can you actually
uh
recover can you actually go the other
direction not starting from something
and proving it but accepting what you
have stated as a theory
if you can obtain the actions that they
were the models that they were actually
having
so i think i think you
so we have to take this offline so you
know you know maybe you give you give
scientific fields too much credit but
they do have access right now but if you
are to develop a computational view of
biology and you can say
evolution by evolutionary biology then
you can say
we can actually redo starting from this
we can actually do everything you were
doing this gives more legitimacy to the
field uh
yeah so uh
that's not you know that that's uh
that's not my style that's not that's
not what i intended to do that's what
that's what i set out to do that's what
i would like what i said in in the
beginning i thought okay
i
uh
i don't want to sort
of i i don't to say that i have i have
sort of you know the ultimate truth and
let me rewrite your books okay so you
know that's not that's not what you know
i i
uh i admire the problems that they
admire
and and
i try to do
so i try to investigate them in my style
and then
using the things that i know
just to make it clear i'm not i'm not
implying anything i'm just stating what
i i want to say so it's not
your questions or you know build some
kind of picture that that i don't
recognize i didn't imply that i'm just
curious if if there can be a foundation
a foundational a more unified's
financial studies that's what okay so so
i'll you know i don't know you you you
are young okay so you know so so in
in the 1940s okay so you know
people people started sort of you know
engineering okay sort of mechanical and
civil engineering right you know what i
said let's build an axiomatic foundation
of complete like somatic film foundation
of
civil engineering okay so you know
they're called rational mechanics okay
it was a huge field okay you know a lot
of a lot of a lot of very smart very
smart mathematicians applied
mathematicians worked on this
it did not have a lasting impact okay so
you know it's not you know these are
these are lofty lofty
projects okay so you know but
um
christopher's had a list of uh fields at
the beginning of his talk that have been
profoundly changed by uh
contamination by computer science ideas
but
primarily the way they've changed has
not been via some axiomatization that's
come from computer science and you might
have to look at each of the individual
fields to see quite what aspect of
computing they've benefited from but
can't think of a single example where
it's been axioms
there's also i mean the general question
you know the role of being able to solve
some models or being able to prove
things about some models is when you
know it sort of found the basis of
generalizing from that and there's
certainly the experience of
metaphysics which is when people really
started looking simple models and trying
to understand those
rather than saying one was going to
learn things from joining his equation
was when the field started really to
take off and progress and then ideas
sort of understanding of why when
there's lots of big numbers around you
know certain things can be universal or
pretty generic and the sort of hope of
those and the getting you know some
intuition from the things that won't get
solved exactly or sometimes prove things
about themselves right so it seems i
mean that it seems that because what
you're you know the models of even some
of the things you're doing except the
fact that you you know
you're proving them is there's a lot of
overlap with you know with approaches
that some physicists might of course of
course uh my take and which models come
naturally is different and somehow which
is i think one of the big benefits here
is i think the kind of models i might
start with are very different and then
one has a similar question about it and
that that back and forth um incidentally
so you know i i did very little to use
the next speaker so you know so you are
going to see a lot more of of of the
computer science mindset sort of you
know in the next in baroon's
lecture
yeah okay so uh
let's maybe break for lunch now but uh
so come back this afternoon for a
discussion of the origin of
complexity and how how complex you can
possibly evolve computational account of
that
okay so let's thank christos